はい それからもうちょこっと
世間の格好いいことに触れてみます
世間の評価の裏 で まあ一応ずっと喋りましたからね
繰り返しですから早く飛ばせます
他人を評価する ほとんど他人をかっこいいと評価するんですよ
世間っていうのは面白いんですよ
かっこいい かっこいいというと
自分のことじゃないんです
他人のことなんです 誰ももう本気になって
私はかっこいい 私はかっこいいと言わないんです
もうそう思ったっても
それ恥ずかしくて隠しちゃうんです
もし女性の方々はね 鏡の前で結構時間経ちなくなりますけどね
かっこいいなと思ってるかもしれませんだけど
まああんまり世間に出てそれを言いふらすっていうことはしないんです
だから世間でかっこいい
かっこいいっていうことは
明らかに他人のこと その人
その他人がどのように思っているのかは関係がないんです
だからかっこいいと言われる人が何を思っているかと
もう興味がないんです
だからタレントさんとかは
もう我々はテレビでちょこちょこっと見てかっこいいと思いますけど
まあまあ ちょっと 30分の番組で喋る時間っていうのは分 1 分
2 分でしょうし もうギャーギャーギャーギャーくだらないことばっかり流れてますし
同じクリップをね だいたい計算したら 4回繰り返すんです
だからもうただ座っているだけでね
本人がそれでかっこいいと思っているでしょうかと思いますけどね
まあ自分一人芝居だったらもう 2時間
3時間  2時間半でも持てるのに
テレビに出たらもうずっと一言葉喋って
それで終わっ 番組も終わってとかね
だからそれでも それにはすごく時間かかったり
苦労したり 朝早く起きたり
夜遅くまでとか ものすごい苦労するんですよ
だから本人が自分のことかっこいいと思ってるかないかね
それは別な話 それでかっこよさの悪いところは
世間がちやほやすると悪いでしょうね
みんなあのポーズして
あのポーズしてくださいとか何とか言うと
やっぱりみんなもうお金も払っているしね
そうすると その世間の評価に自分が乗らなくちゃいけないイメージに
特にこの芸能世界っていうのはもう最悪の世界だと思いますね
もう一人一人が自分のイメージを作って
イメージキャラクターを作って
それに沿って演じるんですね
本当はそうじゃないんです
人々は 例えばさんまさんという人はすごいだらしないキャラクターイメージを演じるんですけど
もうえらい真剣で真面目でものすごい暗い人だそうです
話を聞いてみると しかし
もうカメラを向けると
もういきなりもういい加減でもうだらしないイメージを見せてあげたりする
それにしか視聴者が慣れてないんですね
だから苦しいんじゃないかなと思います
乗らなくちゃいかない
で 何に乗るかというと
俗世間の評価に乗らなくちゃいけない
相手を評価する自分が他人の真似をしようとして苦労したり
失敗したりする それで一般人も誰かさんの真似するでしょ
誰かさんの服を着たり
誰かさんの髪のヘアスタイルを真似たりとかね
歩き方を真似たりとか
大変苦しいんですけどね
それで我々はもうかっこいいと思う人の真似しようとする
かっこいい人々と その人々も世間のイメージに自分を合わせよう合わせようとして
お互い様 わざと苦労しているだけ
その形だけのかっこいいことだからね
かっこいい人に支配され
使用されることもあります
それでこの追っかけとかありますね
まあ本当におかしいんですけど
どこへ行っても自分好きなタレントさんがいるところ
どこでも追っかけていったりとかね
そうなってくると その本人は気にしませんだけど
自分が自分の妄想でも使用されているんですね
自分が好きなタレントさんが日本全国どこへ行ったとしても
自分が行きますよとかね
そこでもうちょっとでも目線が自分の方に行ったら
もう入ったらものすごい喜んだりとかね
本人は全然もう舞台の上だからね
もう客が真っ暗でしょうしね
見えないでしょうし で
そういうなんかおかしい世界が出てきちゃうんですね
ですから 表磨いてもというよね
世間の言う格好っていうのは
この上辺をとにかくなんとかすることなんですよ
かっこいいと認められる
またはそのように思っている人の心が汚れやすいんですよ
まあヨンさんであろうと
みんなものすごく もう日本であれほど大騒ぎしちゃうと
それによって本人の心がどんどんどんどん汚れていくんです
かなり危ない道なんです
人気者の道っていうのは
相手がかっこいいと思う人の心も汚れやすい
それで相手がっていうのは
私が何々さんがかっこいいと思うでしょ
そうすると私の心が汚れているんです
なんてかっこいいでしょうかと思いますから
もう心の中で感情が生まれている
なんてセクシーでしょうかとかね
もう男の場合はそう思いますからね
もう女性だったらなんてかっこいいでしょうかと思っちゃう
どちらでも欲でも汚れているんです
だから私があの人かっこいいと思うことは
私にとってはとんでもない危険な行為なんです
心が汚れちゃうんです
それで我々があの人かっこいいとチヤホヤすると
その人もかわいそうで
心が汚れて汚れていっちゃうんです
傲慢になったり 身を張ったり
いろいろ 傲慢 嫉妬 恨み
欲 怒り 怠けなどが簡単に現れます
だから 俗世間のこのかっこいいって
この一言葉っていうのは
本当に地雷みたいなもんなんですよ
踏んだらもうもう知ったもんじゃないんです
足が離れ離れなくなっちゃいます
大変なことなんです 怪我します
かっこよさが消えるので落ち込んだりもする
それから次の問題は いくらかっこいいって言ったって
これがどんどん減っていくんですよ
人間っていうのはそういう好きなもうアイドルをね
次から次へと作りますからね
あのよく人気ある日本で何娘というんですか？なんとか娘っていうグループがいますね
え？モーニング娘 という
まあやっぱり次から次へと交代しないと
あのかっこよさが守れないんですね
かっこよさが減っていくと
みんなもう出ていくんですね
で 別なものを入れちゃうんです
だから そのモーニング娘
のグループから離れた人々が
まあ自分に能力あればいいんだけど
一人で活動できますから
能力なかったならば まあ普通のババアになっちゃいます
世間のかっこよさが人格を破壊する
だから結論的に言うのは
世間でいうかっこよいというこの概念が
一人一人の人格を破壊するんです
自分だけだったら自分一人地獄に行ったってもいいんだけど
これ周りももう引き連れて
相手の人も関係ない人も引きずれますから
我々は有名人とは会ったこともないし
握手したこともないかもしれませんだけど
我々はその人を有名人に仕立てるんだから
その人まで引きずって悪の道を歩む羽目になるんです
表面的真面目に苦行者のしきたりを守っているある行者に
釈尊がこういう風に説くんです
それでこれ かっこいい世界とはちょっと違いますけど
ある行者がいたんで すごい真面目でもう見ただけですごい行者ではないかとわかるように
すごいかっこつけてあったんです
インドの行者っていうのは
見たらすぐわかります
裸でいるとかね 体に泥塗ってるとかね
髪の毛はもう大体 20年洗ってないとか
そういう自慢げにね まあいろいろあります
あるいはもう針とかね
口を通してはったり 舌を通してはったりとかね
で まあ日本でも行者でなくても
まあ唇やら鼻やらいろんなところでももうつけてはりますけど
そういうかっこつける
だから宗教家もすごくかっこつけるんですよ
まあキリスト教の場合をね
カトリック教会はものすごくかっこつけてるんですね
それからロシアのオーソドックスクリスチャン
なんとかというね まあかっこつけるというとキリがない
かっこつけるんですね
それですごい立派な宗教家というね
日本の仏教は負けてはいませんだけど
まあプロテスタントはあまり格好はつけませんしね
ごく普通の服装でいるとかね
で ヒンドゥー教もね 結構かっこつけちゃうし
キンテージャターヒドゥンメーデキンテーアジナサーティアアッバンタランテーガハナンバーヒランパリマッジェス
だから宗教家がね ものすごい髪の毛をなんとかして
特別な服を着て 特別な歩き方をして
特別な食べ物を食べて
特別な座り方で座ったり
特別な道具を持ったり
真言密教みたいにね いると
みんななんてすごい方でしょうかと手を合わせるんだからね
だから一般人に拝んでもらいたく
尊敬されてもらいたく
あらゆる儀式 表面的にやっちゃうんですよ
だから宗教の世界のこの表面的磨きも
タレントさんの世界ともまるっきり同じなんです
タレントさんもみんなのイメージに合わせて演じて演じてそれで生きていますよ
金もらって 宗教の世界の劇は同じことをやっています
それで お釈迦様はすごくそれには叱るんです
キンテージャタイドゥンメーデ
ドゥンメーデというのは愚か者よ
馬鹿者よ すごい厳しく言うんです
キンテージャター ジャターっていうのは髪の毛を前に頭の上で結んでいることなんです
正田さんの訳があります
修行は浅きものよと 馬鹿者じゃないんです
これは えっ？うん 結髪
あなたにとって何になるというのだろう
だからその人がお釈迦様に怒られた人が
この髪の毛は全部揃って頭の上で結んであるんです
それは破る 外したりはしません
今までのシーク教の男たちは
いつでも髪の毛を頭の上で結んでますよ
しかし シーク教の人々はすごい清潔なんですね
だからちゃんと髪の毛を
男たちの髪の毛長いんです
切りません で これきちんと洗って
しっかりすごい清潔なヒンドゥー教の人々よりは
それがちっちゃな子供でも全部髪の毛を上に結んでおいて
それからターバンで巻いて
もう学校でもどこでも行くんです
それはもう絶対外せません
これ外すのは夜寝る時だけ
だからまあシーク教でですかっていうことは
すぐ見たらわかるんです
で まあシーク教はまあそんなに苦行する宗教ではなくて
まあただ商人たちですから
ほとんどみんな商売やっています
みんなほどの金持ちです
だから贅沢していますけどね
だから不潔わけには全くないんです
ちっちゃな男たちでもね
ターバンつけてると結構かわいいんです
また逆に うん だからこれは宗教だからね
まあターバン これターバンは何の意味でしょうかと
それからあなたにとって
これは 革衣が何になるのでしょうかと
アジナサーティアっていうのはなんとかこの鹿の革をこうやって着ています
衣として アッバンタランテーガハナン
あなたの頭の中はものすごくぐちゃぐちゃ汚れているんだ
臭いんだよと ガハナンというのはそういう意味なんです
外見たらすっかりした行者ですけど
心の中はもうとんでもないんだよという意味なんです
あなたには内なる欲望の
なんとかわからない補足がある
あなたは外に見てくれを
作っている  私はそんな日本語わかりません
これは正田さんの訳で
私の訳で言えばね 外だけあなたはかっこつけてるんですけど
心が臭いんだよって意味なんです
だから心が腐って臭っているんだから
あなたの外のこの飾りは何の意味もないんだよという単純な意味なんです
お釈迦様おっしゃったかったのは
この馬鹿者という この馬鹿者
外を見ると立派なこと
しかし心の中は臭いでしょうと
そういうわけで 世間でいうかっこよさっていうのは
仏教から見れば臭いんです
だって心は汚れますからね